existe uma confusão e um mistério em
relação à erva cidreira e suas variações
Melissa cidreira brasileira e capim
limão são todas conhecidas como erva
cidreira eu vou explicar a diferença e
colocar as imagens na tela para vocês
entenderem a Melissa oficinais é
conhecida como a verdadeira erva
cidreira com folhas menores que lembram
a hortelã e tem um aroma marcante já a
alípia Alba ou erva cidreira brasileira
possui folhas maiores e aroma suave
ambas são sinais mas a Melissa se
destaca no alívio do estresse e
ansiedade não confunda com o delicioso
capim limão com suas folhas alongadas e
que é perfeito para digestão gases e
cólicas Você já experimentou o chá de
algum tipo de erva cedre Ira compartilha
aqui nos comentários como é que essa
maravilha natural tem melhorado a sua
vida eu quero saber os benefícios que
você sentiu ok